we know during the pandemic we've seen a  record number of drug overdoses and  addiction it turns out it's even  impacting pregnant and postpartum  mothers drug-induced deaths is the  number one leading cause of death for  women of a reproductive age there's a  program at roseman university college of  medicine working to target pregnant  opioid users the program is called  empowered participants receive medical  treatment therapy and parenting classes  now they are providing even more support  services to help mothers keep their  children  if you have a safe and healthy mom  you're more likely to have a safe and  healthy baby you have a safe and healthy  household whatever that looks like  you're more likely to have a safe and  healthy mom and baby  so far the program has helped more than  200 mothers